The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we have an
interesting class today.
We're going to be taking
this IV curve that we've so
laboriously set up and
understood-- sorry about that.
And now we will subject
it to illumination.
So that's the essence
of our lecture today,
the diode under illumination.
And as part of
today's lecture, we
have some wonderful
little kits over there
in the corner where
we'll actually be testing
IV curves of solar cells.
So I hope some of you
brought the computers today,
and if not, we have some extras
up here as well we can use.
So again, just to
situate ourselves.
We're here in fundamentals.
We're approaching the end
of our fundamental section,
but we still have a few
really important lectures
to get through.
After we get through
the fundamentals,
we'll be in a good
position to understand
the different
technologies and finally
the cross-cutting themes.
And our goal is to, at
least for the fundamentals,
to understand solar
cell conversion
efficiency, which is the ratio
of output to input energy.
And for most solar
cells, this breaks down
to the following progression,
from the solar spectrum
to charge collection.
And we're going to be
focusing on charge separation,
incorporating elements
of either side
but mostly focused on
charge separation today.
reminding everybody, of
course, that the total system
efficiency is the product of
each individual efficiency.
And if any one of these
is low, the efficiency
for the entire system is low.
And since folks are tired of
looking at this chart by now,
every single lecture I intend
to introduce something new that
follows a similar pattern.
Does anybody recognize
what this is about?
So you have over
here some H2O going
into an oxygen-evolving
complex, and light is coming in,
essentially exciting
up an electron,
which is being stored in
some form of chemical energy.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Photosynthesis.
PROFESSOR:
Photosynthesis, right?
And just like a solar cell,
the photosynthesis conversion
efficiency of the
entire system is
dictated by the efficiency
of each individual part.
Roughly it can be broken down to
this little pie chart up here.
The total system
efficiency in blue
is somewhere, depending
on the plant, somewhere
around 1%, maybe as
high as 7% or 8%,
depending on very
specialized plants that
are experts at converting
sunlight into usable chemical
energy.
And that, in part, is largely
due to optical losses.
If you can see the absorption
spectrum of chlorophyll,
of the different types
of chlorophyll here,
you'll see large portions
of the solar spectrum that
go underutilized.
So again, another system
that's similar to a solar cell,
that the total
system efficiency is
the product of each individual
component going on here.
All right.
So now what we're going
to do is just quickly
revisit the diode in the dark
and construct the energy band
diagram for pn-junction
in the dark.
Each of you should have
on your desk these sheets.
Oh, we don't have
them on the desks.
We need to pass those out.
So we should have
sheets that describe
essentially the equivalent
circuit diagram, the IV
characteristics,
and the energy band
diagram for our
pn-junction in the dark.
We laboriously filled
this out last class.
We're just going to
refresh ourselves
to make sure we're
all on the same page
and redo it this class
right at the beginning
because it's that important.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you for those
who came to our office
hours and for those
who came to the
recitations, and we really
tried to get this across.
For those who are
still struggling,
let's make sure that you get
this sometime between now
and, say, the next
two weeks because this
will feature
prominently on the exam,
and it's pretty important
for understanding
how a solar cell works.
So if you would not mind working
directly with your partner,
the person who's sitting
directly next to you.
Let's walk through
the diode in the dark
and construct the
energy band diagrams
for the diode in the dark.
I'll walk you through it
as soon as you've done.
Maybe I'll give you three
minutes to complete that.
And then we'll progress to
the diode under illumination.
Should be a lot of fun.
I see convergence among several
of you, so let's move forward.
Just to review quickly,
the way I typically
think about it, if we set up in
the model circuit right here,
we have our pn-junction.
We have our space-charge
region, also
known as the quasi-neutral
region, also known
as the depletion zone.
So we have this
region right here
that represents the
space-charge region.
So this is in the dark.
Now we have the
energy band diagram
shown right here, where this
dashed blue line represents
the chemical potential, also
called the Fermi energy,
throughout the entire device
right here in cross-section.
And just to be very,
very clear, we've
so far described
the solar cell as
like coming in through the top.
And now we've rotated this
structure by 90 degrees
to represent the pn-junction.
That's been a little
confusing for some folks.
So just to be totally clear,
in a device like this one,
if it were subject
to illumination
you would have light coming
in from the side, right,
either from the p side
or from the n side.
So to transfer this
into what we've
seen so far with the solar
cell devices facing up
toward the sun, you'd have
to rotate this by 90 degrees,
right?
Just to make sure we're all
clear with orientations.
[? Because ?] we have the
Fermi energy right here.
The drift and diffusion currents
for electrons-- electron
diffusion, electron
drift-- there
is an abundance of electrons
over here in the n-type side,
and so they want to
diffuse over to the p-type.
That's why the diffusion
current is pointing left.
Once they do to
a certain degree,
they set up a field,
the electrons and holes,
the mobile charges
set up a field,
and that creates a drift current
that counteracts the diffusion.
And once these two
are in equilibrium,
there's no current flowing
through our device.
That's why current is
equal to 0 right here.
And there's also no
potential difference
because the Fermi energy,
the chemical potential,
is the same on either
side of that device,
and so the voltage
output of that solar cell
would also be 0.
When we forward bias our device,
now we're forcing a separation,
or we're forcing a separation
of the chemical potential
on either side of the device.
If you connected this
to an external circuit,
the electrons would want to flow
from this side to that side.
But since we're forcing this
condition here with a battery,
we are reducing the
barrier height here.
Electrons can now diffuse
over from the n-type
into the p-type
side, and they do.
And the diffusion
current increases.
And that's why we have
current now a positive value.
We've defined the electrons
traveling to the left
as being a positive current.
We have now electrons
traveling from the n-type
to the p-type material.
When we reverse bias our
device, notice the separation
of the quasi-Fermi energies.
Again, we have here
one sign of voltage
because the right side
is higher than the left.
And now the right side
is lower than the left,
so our voltage sign
flips from right
to left over here from
positive to negative values.
So notice the voltage.
And now the current as well.
The drift current will
outweigh the diffusion current
in this particular case because
now the barrier for electrons
to diffuse from
the n to the p-type
is very large they'll have
difficulty going from that side
to that side.
Whereas the drift
current is larger because
of the larger electric field.
And as a result, the drift
current will dominate.
And so now instead
of electrons flowing
from n-type to p-type,
where we had defined
as positive current, electrons
are flowing from p-type
to n-type in that, which we
defined as negative current.
And that's why our
current has changed signs.
Over here, notice that we're
in positive current territory,
and over here, notice we're
in negative current territory.
Also, you'll notice the width
of the space-charge region
changing as we forward and
reverse bias our device.
As the barrier
height decreases, we
have a decrease of the
built-in electric field.
We have a decrease of
the amount of charge
on either side of the junction.
That's why the depletion
width decreases.
And the opposite happens
here under reverse bias.
So getting to the point where
you can set up a pn-junction
and understand how drift
and diffusion currents come
into being in the
first place and then
being able to bias your diode
under different conditions
is a really important
fundamental skill
for understanding how
a solar cell works.
Question.
AUDIENCE: On the forward
and reverse bias,
does the Fermi energy
actually continuous,
or does it actually [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So the Fermi
energy, which we defined here
as the chemical
potential, notice
we're avoiding
talking about what's
happening here in the middle
until a couple of lectures
from now.
That gets into a gray
zone where we talk
about quasi-Fermi energies.
We'll get to that in a minute
or maybe a couple of lectures.
But yes, the Fermi energy in
the extreme sides right here
near the contacts,
so your contact
in your device over here and
your contact in your device
over here, those
Fermi energies are
different on an
absolute energy scale.
So there is an energy
difference when
you're driving the electrons
from one side to the other.
Notice in this case
right here, you
would think that
the electrons would
want to travel through
an external circuit
to come back to this side
because their energy's higher
in this side and
lower over here.
But we're not illuminating
the solar cell yet.
We're biasing it
using a battery.
And this is why we have current
flow coming from this side
into that side.
We're essentially forcing
the electrons from the n-type
into the p-type material.
We're pushing them up
that hill with a battery.
And that's why we have this
diffusion current dominating
in the dark, in the dark.
So we have a current
flowing from right to left.
In the illuminated
case, we'll have
all of our carriers
traveling from left to right.
And in the dark,
this is the only case
in which we have carriers
traveling from right to left.
And it's happening because we're
using that battery in the dark
to change the chemical
potential on either side, which,
in effect, reduces
this barrier height
and allows carriers to diffuse
from the n-type into p-type.
So you can think about
it as forcing carriers
up the junction.
And this is a very
useful technique
because, in effect, what
it's doing in a real device,
when we you have a
two-dimensional device
within homogeneities,
the current
will travel through the weakest
point of that pn-junction.
Wherever the barrier
height is lowest, current
will begin crowding
through that spot.
And so it's a way of
probing or testing
the quality of your junction
characteristic in the dark.
OK.
So this is the basics of
pn-junction in the dark.
Let's flip our page
over and now let's
try to imagine what will happen
under illuminated conditions,
and let's start out
in a very simple case.
We'll assume that the
principle of superposition
applies here, that the
photo-excited carriers--
in other words, when light
shines into our device--
I'm looking at this one right
now or this one right here--
and light's coming in and
generating electron-hole pairs,
essentially exciting
electrons across the band gap
like we described in lecture 3,
so we have carriers now being
excited across
the band gap, what
will happen to
those electrons now
that they're in the
conduction band?
Where will they want to go?
AUDIENCE: To the right.
PROFESSOR: To the right, right?
OK.
So what you'll do
is set up what's
called an illumination current.
Notice now at the bottom
of the second row here,
you have electron diffusion,
electron drift, and IL current.
IL stands for
illumination current.
So you have a third
arrow here that
will have to be
implemented in some way.
And that will-- by the
principle of superposition
you should think what happens
to your IV curve as well.
So let's make an estimate of
what we think should happen,
and then I'll confer
some notes, and then
we'll measure what actually
does happen under illumination.
Why don't we give it a shot?
What does forward
and reverse bias
mean when there's no battery?
This is a very
interesting question.
So once you start illuminating
your solar cell device
and you start injecting carriers
into it, what will happen is,
very naturally,
this band alignment
that you see right
here, this band diagram,
will begin to shift toward
the forward bias condition.
Rationale?
You'll be generating carriers.
They'll be swept over
into this region here.
One way to think
about is that you'll
be increasing the number
of electrons over here
and the number of holes over
here, which will naturally
cause the energy
of those electrons
to increase on this side,
the chemical potential
on this side, to increase.
So one way to think
about it is, as you're
illuminating your solar
cell more and more and more,
you're forcing a forward bias
condition on your device.
To get the solar cell
to go into reverse bias,
you really do need
to bias your device.
You physically need to bias it.
Yeah.
So when I mentioned
illumination current here,
we're really talking about
the electron illumination
current, right, what
direction of travel
the electrons are taking
inside of our system.
So yes, the electrons would be
traveling from left to right.
Very astute observation.
Current is generally described
as a flow of positive charge.
And in the absence of a definer
or, say, electrons or holes,
you rightly could
assume that it would be
the flow of positive charges.
We're assuming electrons
are flowing here
in the illumination. current.
Good.
All right.
So This is very positive.
I see everybody has
settled on the notion
that illumination will
shift our IV curve down.
Because of the way
we've defined current,
that if current flows from
left to right that lands us
in negative current territory.
So that makes sense.
If we shine light
on our system, we
have electrons flowing
from left to right here.
That'll put us into
negative territory.
So that shifts the
entire thing down.
And we would add illumination
current, an arrow pointing
to the right right
here, which would
mean that we would have current
flowing through our device,
but there's still no difference
in the chemical potential
on either side.
There's still a
difference in Fermi energy
in the p-type and
the n-type, which
means our voltage is equal to 0,
which means we're intersecting
the y-axis right
here, and our little x
should be marked
right down here.
So it's really just
a superposition.
Great.
OK.
Now what happens if we
forward bias our device either
because we're adding a resistor
in series to our solar cell?
So instead of a
battery there, you
would replace that
with a resistor.
Or if we're applying a
bias voltage as well,
we could also do that
under illumination.
So we'd still have the
illumination current, right?
And we, through superposition,
shift this entire curve down,
we'd be operating somewhere
in this quadrant right there,
right?
So this we call IV quadrant,
typically I, II, III, IV, IV
quadrant.
This is where power is coming
out of the solar cell device.
Because if we imagine instead
of having a battery there,
we have a resistor,
the electrons
will travel from
the n-type material
through that external load to
get work the p-type material
where the chemical
potential is lower, right,
because they'll desire to
minimize their free energy.
And as a result, they'll
deposit that power
across that resistor,
across that external load,
in order to get back
to this other side
because that's the only path
that they can travel easily,
right?
And so this entire
curve shifts down.
You have your red x somewhere
in the quadrant over here.
And power is flowing
out of the solar cell
across that external load.
So in the next slide,
pretty much everything
is right, except
that, mea culpa,
I forgot to replace
the battery up there
with a little resistor.
So you'll want to correct
that in your notes.
Instead of having the
little batteries up there,
you can replace
those with resistors
or a resistor in series with
a battery, if you prefer.
Since depending on the
illumination condition,
the intensity we may have
natural for a bias condition,
we may need to apply
a bias voltage.
OK.
So we have our IV
characteristic like this.
We have our red x under
forward bias conditions
in the IV quadrant,
denoting that power
would be flowing out of
this solar cell device
under these conditions.
And now the bias is inverted.
We have reverse bias conditions.
And notice that the current
still has the same sign.
So the current is negative
here, negative here,
and negative here.
So the net current is always
flowing in the same direction
in all cases because we have
this illumination current,
because we have this
generation of carriers
inside of the material.
That's pretty cool.
That wasn't the case when we
had the device in the dark.
Here, in the forward
bias conditions,
we're actually forcing carriers
from the n-type material
into the p-type material.
But under illumination,
now we have
all of our carriers
traveling from the p-type
into the n-type.
What's varying is the potential
that the carriers have
and, of course, the
total amount of current.
As you forward bias
more and more and more,
this downhill slope
here decreases, right?
So there's less of a driving
force for the carriers
to be going from the
p-type to the n-type,
and that's why the
current approaches 0.
Eventually at some point, if
you keep forward biasing here,
the current will be 0.
There will be no
net current flow
because there will be no
driving force for the carriers
to go from the p-type
into the n-type.
There will be no
more built-in field.
Kind of cool.
OK.
So now we're beginning to
wrap our heads around what's
happening to the
electrons and holes
during solar cell operation.
Let me put a little bit
of mathematics to this.
These are your IV curves.
The blue is in the dark, and
the red is under illumination.
And we're focused
on this IV quadrant
right here because this is
the quadrant in which power
is coming out of our
solar cell device,
which usable power
is coming out that we
can power an external load.
Why?
Well, first off,
the voltage is such
that we can power
an external load.
We have charge separation.
The electrons are
accumulated over here.
And they have higher
potential than they
do on the other side,
which means that there's
an incentive for them to go
through the external circuit,
deposit the power across
that external load
to get back to this other side
where their potential is lower,
right?
So the voltage is favorable.
And the current
is also favorable
because now we have
light coming in.
And this generation current is
driving the carriers-- well,
or is creating carriers
here in the p-type that
can then be driven
toward the n-type because
of the built-in field.
So the conditions are just right
under illuminated forward bias
conditions to drive power
through our external load.
Under all other conditions of
operations of the solar cell,
we're putting power into the
device, not getting power out
of it.
This IV quadrant over
here, this forward bias
illuminated case is the only
case in which power is coming,
usable power is coming out of
our solar cell that we can use.
So that's why we focus on
this IV quadrant right here.
The illuminated IV curve
is, to the first order,
is just your dark IV curve
with a superposition, which
we call the illumination
current, I sub L.
And that's what shifts our
entire curve down by this I sub
L right here, so this I sub L,
that one right there or that
right there.
Kind of cool.
All right.
What do we think will happen if
our light intensity goes down
by a factor of 2?
So now if the amount of sunlight
falling on our solar cell
drops by 1/2, what will happen?
What do we predict will happen
based on this right here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The curve will shift,
the red curve will shift up
by about 1/2, right, because
the illumination current is now
cut in half.
What will happen to the
voltage intersect right here?
What is the relation
between voltage and current?
It's the logarithmic
relation, right?
So it won't necessarily
be cut in half, right?
But it'll be cut by whatever
this would be here, a log of 2.
So OK.
So we're beginning to develop
an intuitive understanding
of where electrons
are flowing inside
of our solar cells in the
dark and under illumination.
In the dark is
important because we
can test our
devices in the dark,
and we can still learn a lot
about our solar cell device
characteristics in the dark.
As well, we can, under forward
bias conditions in the dark,
we can force carriers from
one side of the junction
to the other the wrong way
and probe for weaknesses
in the pn-junction regions.
That's helpful.
And in the
illumination condition,
obviously we're testing the
total amount of power that's
coming out of our device.
So again, this is very
useful because It's
off of this red
curve here that we
defined the efficiency or the
performance of the solar cell.
So what I'll ask
folks to do now is
to-- we'll begin passing
around these little tools.
And I'll ask David
Berney Needleman
to come up to the front.
David is our lab guru.
He's the one who
helped build these,
really was the driving force
behind getting them built.
These are IV testers
that will allow
you to measure the current
voltage characteristics
of solar cells
right here in class.
And he's going to--
well, we'll pass them out
while maybe he comes
to the front here
and explains how they work.
So now that we have the
basic IV curves rolling in,
what I'd like you to
do is modify the height
or the intensity of the light.
And the easiest way to
modify the intensity of light
is to move the light
position up and down.
So modify the
intensity of the light
and see how this
IV curve changes.
Note the y-axis scale,
which might change as well.
It might rescale depending
on the condition.
But note the y-axis
scale and see
how the intercept of
the y-axis is changing
with illumination intensity.
Give that a shot.
All right, folks.
Why don't we circle
back real quick.
This has been a good experiment.
I am very much in favor of
multitasking and browsing.
So if you want to keep your
experiment running over
the course of the
remainder of the lecture,
I will certainly
have nothing opposed
to testing a few different
illumination conditions.
And if there's anything
really, really important
I'm going to emphasize, this
is a really important wake-up,
folks.
The I sub L, just to
really recap here,
we have this ideal
diode equation,
the illumination current coming
in from our light source.
And in our little set-up,
how many batteries
did you see there?
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: Look closer.
How many batteries do you
see total in our set-up?
Look especially at
that light source.
Two of them, right?
There's a 9-volt and
a 1.5-volt. All right.
So one of them is
powering the light source.
And we have, as well, bias to
the solar cell device, right?
So we have a bit of a
combination of the last two
slides, right?
In this case, in the dark, we
were biasing our solar cell
using the battery.
And in the illumination
conditions, the light
itself was causing the solar
cell to become forward biased.
But we can add a battery
to sweep the bias
condition of the device, right?
So even though we have a natural
biasing of the solar cell
by the light, we can
force the solar cell
under different operating
conditions with the battery.
And so that's effectively
what's happening right here
is you have a combination
of both simple scenarios
that we just looked
at, and we're
building on those components
to really understand
the larger system.
Why might that be important,
or why might that be realistic?
Well, the light
itself is biasing
that particular
solar cell device.
But that solar cell
might be connected
in series with a bunch of other
solar cells in a module, right?
And those other
solar cells might
be biasing that one solar cell.
So that's why we have to think
about the solar cell device
both from the perspective
of what bias condition is it
under, what illumination
is it under,
and of course, what's
happening around it.
Is it just powering
an external load?
Is there a battery
connected in series to it?
Are there other solar cells
connected in series with it?
OK.
Yes, Ashley?
AUDIENCE: So I don't understand
still why having a load
would bias the device.
PROFESSOR: So let's imagine
under illumination conditions
right here, what I'm
going to do very,
very quickly is replace this
battery manually in my slides,
if PowerPoint auto save will
allow me, with a resistor.
So if you'll excuse my
quick introduction here
of the resistor.
Now, sorry about the
little artistic license.
OK.
So now I have my resistor here.
And my illumination is
coming into the device
from-- say one of the sides is
generating electron-hole pairs.
I have a multiplicity of
electrons that have now
gone down the hill, right?
It's more energetically
favorable for these electrons
to be on the other side.
And what has that done?
It's raised the chemical
potential of this side.
It's difficult for them
to get back the other way.
It's not impossible,
but it could
be more easy for them to flow
through an external circuit
to get back to the other side.
And as they flow through
that external circuit,
they're depositing their energy
across that external circuit.
What energy?
Well, it's the
potential difference
from this side to that side.
So that's why the solar
cell can be thought of, as
in forward bias conditions,
under illumination
with an external
load attached to it.
Of course, the load has to
be well-matched to the output
of the solar cell device.
AUDIENCE: And is the biasing
because there is a voltage drop
across the resistor?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The biasing is because
you have a shift
in the chemical potential of
this side up relative to-- you
have a shift of the n-type side
higher than the p-type side.
That's a bias.
Anytime you have a difference
in the chemical potential
in one terminal versus the other
terminal of your solar cell,
you have a bias.
Whether that's
generated by light,
whether it's generated
by a battery, right,
whether it's the energy input
to create that bias is coming
from the sun or if it's coming
from an external battery,
that's a matter of detail.
AUDIENCE: So is the sun
forward biasing the cell?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
One can think about this as--
AUDIENCE: I thought you were
talking about the difference
between light and the LE-- OK.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
So the LED, in this case, could
forward bias your device, too.
I mean, it's just photons.
Photons are forward
biasing the device.
AUDIENCE: So then can
some ever reverse bias?
PROFESSOR: No.
That would be very
difficult. What you could do,
though, is have a bunch
of solar cells connected
in series with this
one, right, that
are producing forward power.
You could shade this
device, and then power
could be flowing backward
through it, right?
In other words, it could
be in the dark right
here, in a dark condition.
And you could be in a
reverse bias condition
just because of the way the
other solar cells around it
are behaving, if you have a
shaded solar cell, for example,
in a module.
So imagine a seagull lands
and kind of covers up
one of the cells.
That will be under reverse bias,
and that could present problems
if the solar cell can't
withstand the reverse bias.
No, this is a very
ideal condition.
What happens in the real world
is that at some reverse bias
condition, you'll
just have biased it
so much that electrons will
be able to tunnel through
from the p-type into
the n-type right here.
The electrons in the valence
band will be able to tunnel
through into the
conduction band.
And what happens to this
IV curve is it goes zoom,
begins dropping.
So if the solar
cell reverse bias--
let's see, the
reverse bias current,
or the current at reverse bias
voltage, is not low enough,
in other words, if
the pn-junction is not
strong enough, you could
have a catastrophic failure
of your module by just
shading one of your cells.
Thankfully, this is one
of the testings that
are done with the
solar simulator
to prevent that failure mode.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: All right.
I'll entertain deeper
dives with questions.
I'll try to keep
the lecture focused
on the broader general topics.
But if somebody is
interested in learning more,
I'm happy to kind
of dive into there.
All right.
So readings are
strongly encouraged.
I have interacted
with several of you.
Joe has interacted
with probably 3n,
n being the number of people
I've interacted with so far,
and really tried to impart
the wisdom of pn-junctions.
So please, please, please
come to us if still
things are going over your head.
You should be able to explain to
your roommates exactly what is
going on in a pn-junction.
Define parameters that
determine solar cell efficiency.
So now we have a
qualitative sense
about where current is flowing,
where electrons are moving
around, what defines
the power output, how
the power output is changing
with illumination condition.
We're getting an intuitive
sense of all this.
Let's start putting
some discrete variables
to all of that.
And there are a bunch of
two-letter or three-letter
acronyms with some subscripts
here that we'll get to know
and we'll become
very familiar with
over the next few lectures.
So how is solar cell conversion
efficiency determined
from that illuminated IV curve?
That's our first question.
And what I'm going to do
is start with our source
IV curve right here.
This is just the IV quadrant.
OK?
So notice the
current starts at 0
and goes to some negative value.
So we're looking
in the IV quadrant.
Voltage is going from
0 to a positive value.
So again, IV quadrant.
We have our ideal
diode equation here.
And oh, notice one thing.
I just changed I to
J. What just happened?
Well, I and J look very
similar, but they're, in fact,
two different variables.
Most often, PV researchers
will report a current density,
in other words, a current
per unit area instead
of the actual current coming
out of a solar cell device.
So what you've been
measuring here off of the DAC
has been current, total current
output from that device.
And it might be a
really tiny number,
and it might be
difficult to compare
against other-sized devices.
And so what solar
cell researchers often
do is they say, OK, let's
normalize the current
by the area to get
a current density.
And we'll call
current density J,
and we'll call current I, right?
So for calculating
power, we'll have
to use I. We'll have
to multiply I times V.
But if we're just looking at
one solar cell versus another,
we can use J as a very
convenient way of comparing
one solar cell versus another.
Cool.
OK.
So the illuminated IV curve
looks something like this,
right?
It's in the IV quadrant.
It goes out a certain amount,
then it the curves up.
We just determined
that here in class.
And that's essentially
the ideal diode equation
with a superposition term,
this J sub L right there.
So let's parse through this.
We have the
y-intercept over here.
At the y-intercept,
there is maximum current
flowing through the
circuit but no power
because voltage is equal to 0.
So remember, the Fermi energy
is the same on either side.
The chemical
potentials are the same
on either side of the device.
So there's no energy gain
of the electron traveling
through the external circuit,
but there's a maximum current.
And no power flowing through
that external circuit
because there's no
potential to be dropped
across the external resistor.
The opposite happens
over here at this point
called Voc, which we'll
call open-circuit voltage.
The oc stands for open
circuit, V, voltage.
Open-circuit voltage is just
as you would think it is.
When your solar cell is in
an open circuit, when you--
say you took a
pair of scissors--
please don't this--
and cut the leads so
that your solar cell
wasn't outputting
the current through
an external load,
there would be a bias voltage
built up across the p and the n
side of the solar cell.
And it would be
the maximum voltage
that could be supported
by that solar cell device
under illumination conditions.
That's the open-circuit
voltage, open circuit
because there's
no current, again,
traveling through
the external circuit.
That's why current
is 0, open circuit.
And voltage because
this is-- well,
it's an interesting
point because it's
the maximum voltage here
represented in the IV quadrant.
And somewhere in between the
point of open-circuit voltage
and short-circuit current--
short-circuit current,
again, because you're short
circuiting your device--
current is flowing through,
but there's no resistor.
There's no external load.
There's no power being
deposited on external load.
Somewhere between these
two extreme conditions
where there's no power flowing
through the external circuit,
you have a maximum
power point where
there is a power being deposited
across your external circuit
and a lot of it, right?
That's the maximum power point.
This is the point at
which the solar cell
is producing the maximum
amount of power output.
And to represent that
slightly differently, what
I've done-- so if I were
to take current times
voltage right here
using IV quadrant data,
my power would be
a negative number.
Why?
Because voltage is
positive, but current
is a negative number, right?
So I'd multiply a positive
and negative number together,
you get a negative number,
and that just sounds weird.
Who talks about power
output from solar cells
being negative?
It almost sounds like power's
going into the device.
So this is another
convention that you're
going to have to get used to
is looking at the IV curve
in the I quadrant.
So all we've done
is taken the y-axis
and multiplied by a negative 1.
So we flipped it up, right?
So bear with me here.
It's a bit tricky to keep
all this in your RAM.
But here's our short-circuit
current point now.
Here's our open-circuit
voltage point.
Our IV curve now
is pointed down.
Before it was going up because
we were in the IV quadrant.
Now, we flipped,
essentially just
done a-- we've done a flip
vertical, if you will,
on our IV curve, and we have
our current increasing here
going to higher bias voltages.
Now we can take the product
of the voltage and the current
to determine the
power, and we obtain
a curve that looks very
much like this blue curve
right here that you can see.
And the maximum power point
is truth in advertising.
It's at the maximum power.
It's where this blue
curve reaches a maximum.
That is the maximum power
point of the solar cell device.
That is where the solar
cell is outputting
the maximum amount of power.
And so at this
maximum power point,
there is a voltage and a current
associated with it that you can
read right off the IV curve.
And this we call Jmp, or current
density at the maximum power
point, and Vmp, which is the
voltage at the maximum power
point.
So, so far, we've learned
essentially four variables
here.
We have our Jsc, our
Voc, and our Jmp,
and our Vmp at that
data point right there.
Questions, since I
know you have them.
AUDIENCE: To ensure that
the device is working
in the maximum power point,
does an external voltage have
to be applied to it?
PROFESSOR: So to ensure
that the solar cell
device is operating right
here, a couple of things
need to happen.
You need to have the right
illumination conditions,
and you need to
have the right load.
So the two need to be
matched to each other.
Absolutely.
And that's where some
of the power electronics
come into play.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in the
last problem set,
where [INAUDIBLE], we assumed
that output voltage would
be [INAUDIBLE] volts.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that, in
general, a safe assumption
for [INAUDIBLE] solar cell?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
So it's a very interesting
question regarding the homework
question.
Let me repeat it so that
the microphone can hear it.
The homework question
in the last homework,
there was one question
that inquired,
assume that the voltage
at the maximum power point
is the band gap voltage
equivalent minus 0.5 volts.
And the rationale for that
assumption is as follows.
The open-circuit
voltage, this point,
is generally between 0.35 and
0.4 volts minus the band gap,
or lower than the band gap.
So you have the band gap
energy minus 0.4 volts.
And I can show you a
very nice little paper
that describes why that is.
It essentially has
to do, in part,
with losses inside of the solar
cell at thermodynamic limits
of conversion inside of
the solar cell device.
Then what we've
done is we've done
another additional discounting
from the Voc to the maximum
power point, which we've assumed
is around 0.1, maybe 0.2 volts.
Notice the shape of the
IV curve right here.
The maximum power
point is interesting
because the voltage at
the maximum power point
is almost the Voc,
in a good device.
And the current at the
maximum power point
is almost Jsc, but not quite.
All right?
So the discounting from the
Voc to the maximum power
point voltage is not that
much, as is the discounting
from the short-circuit
current to the maximum power
point in a good device.
In a bad device, this
maximum power point
here could be dragged
all way down here.
You could have an IV curve that
looked something more like this
instead, almost like a
resistor, at which point
the maximum power output would
be a lot less, a lot less
than what's shown
here in blue curve.
Cool.
All right.
So let's continue moving on.
The efficiency of
the solar cell.
Eta, this Greek letter eta, is
our power out versus power in.
Our power in is the
illumination intensity
given in units of watts
per meter squared.
So we calculated this in our
very first homework assignment
and realized that the AM
1.5 spectrum is around
1,000 watts per meter squared.
So that's our input
power right here.
Our output power is the
voltage at the maximum power
point times--
whoopsy-- times the
current at the
maximum power point,
not the current
density, the current
at the maximum power point.
So take this current
density and multiply
by area, and that's
effectively-- the units
work out better that way.
So it would be either V times
I at the maximum power point
or V times J times the area,
the area of the device,
the area of the solar cell,
at the maximum power point.
And that's the total power out.
Actually, yeah, yeah.
So as long as the units are
in units of watts per meter
squared-- yeah, down here-- if
this is not total watts but,
watts per meter
squared, you could still
use current density.
Those units would
still work out.
So be very careful whether
you use total power in
or normalized by unit
area power, right?
Just keep track of your units.
Don't do like the professor.
OK.
So we have efficiency here
as power out versus power in,
the power out being the maximum
power point power and the power
in being the illumination
from the sun.
Now we're really talking.
This is starting to get
interesting because it's
beginning to click.
Pieces from lecture
number 2 come together
with what we're seeing now.
So this is solar cell output
power at the maximum power
point and sunlight coming in.
OK.
So what I'm going
to do next is I'm
going to take this
maximum power point
and I'm going to draw a box
that starts at the origin here,
and the kitty-corner
corner of my box
is going to end at the
maximum power point.
So it'll have some
rectilinear shape that
will comprise the
maximum power point
and 0, 0, the origin,
as two of its corners.
And that box looks like
this blue one right here.
The area of that box
is Jmp times Vmp.
OK?
And notice I have
another box around here.
I have this clear box
that starts at the Voc
point and the Jsc point.
And now I have two rectilinear
shapes, this blue one
and the clear one right
here, the bigger one.
The bigger one has an
area of Jsc times Voc.
And I'm going to define
a parameter called
fill factor, which will be
the ratio of these two areas,
the ratio of those two boxes,
the Vmp times Jmp divided
by the Voc and Jsc.
If this is 1, which is
virtually impossible to do,
but if this were 1, it
would mean that these two
boxes were the same size.
And the current and voltage
at the maximum power points
would be the current
and voltage under
short-circuit and open-circuit
conditions respectively.
In real life, this blue box
is smaller than the square box
right over here.
And so the Jmp Vmp product is
less than the Jsc Voc product.
And by consequence
as well, the Jmp
is less than the Jsc,
Vmp is less than Voc.
So the ratio of the two boxes
is defined as the fill factor.
The fill factor indicates
the quality of your diode.
If your fill factor
is very poor,
that means that that sun right
over there at its maximum power
point is being dragged
toward the origin.
That means that the
area of this blue box
is growing smaller relative
to the area of this clear box.
The fill factor is going down.
That means you're filling less
of this maximum square box
function defined by the Voc Jsc.
OK.
So we have defined efficiency
as power out divided
by power in, power out
being the current voltage
product of the maximum
power point divided
by the solar
insulation, fill factor
being defined as the ratio
of Vmp Imp product divided
by Voc Ioc product.
Notice that here I've written
this in terms of total current,
here in terms of
current density.
The areas essentially
just cancel out
because you have an area in
the numerator and denominator.
They cancel.
These ratios should
be identical.
Thus we obtain an expression
for the efficiency in terms
of fill factor, Voc, and Ioc.
Simply by using this fill
factor definition right here,
what I've done is
I've multiplied
this side of the
equation-- let's just
focus right here--
where we have fill
factor equals Vmp times Imp
divided by Voc times Ioc.
I moved the denominator
up to the side
over here, multiplied it by fill
factor, and that's my Vmp Imp.
Now, I go back to
that top equation
and say my Vmp Imp is now
going to be substituted
by fill factor
times Voc times Ioc,
and that's how I get to
this equation right here.
Why?
Why do I go through the effort
of this little numerical
manipulation?
I do it because these
parameters right here
are fairly easy to measure
using the solar simulator
that you just put together.
So I can measure the point
at which my voltage is
at open-circuit condition.
I can measure the current
at short-circuit condition.
And simply by taking the
ratio of those boxes,
I can determine what my
fill factor is as well.
And these break down roughly
into the current is going
to be a function roughly--
again, I'm really painting
broad brush strokes here--
the current is going
to be roughly a function of
illumination condition and bulk
material quality.
The Voc will be roughly a
function of the interface
and the diode characteristics.
And the fill factor
is going to be
a function of the interface
diode characteristics
but also of the resistances
within the device.
And so from an
engineering point of view,
when we break the solar cell
output down into these three
parameters so that we can
better understand what's
going wrong with our solar cell.
If we have everything
lumped in terms of Vmp Imp,
it becomes a little bit
more obscure to figure out
what exactly is going wrong
with our solar cell device.
Ashley?
AUDIENCE: You said
the fill factor also
an easily measurable parameter?
PROFESSOR: So the fill factor
you would measure essentially
by doing the little analysis
we just did right here.
Yeah, exactly.
So you'd have to do a
voltage current sweep.
Mm-hmm.
Coolness.
OK.
So we have an expression
for efficiency
in terms of fill factor, Voc,
Ioc and our incoming power.
So power out, this
right here again
is power out,
divided by power in.
Why does efficiency matter?
Why do we care so
much about efficiency?
Well, the conversion
efficiency determines
the area of solar cells needed
to produce a certain peak
power, or to think
of it differently,
the area of solar panels
that is necessary to produce
a certain energy per unit time.
And many costs scale with area.
You have glass, encapsulants,
the absorbent materials
within the solar cell
devices themselves,
the metals that are
used to make contacts,
the labor that's used
to install the panels.
If you have a larger
panel area, you
need more labor to install it.
The aluminum and racking
and framing materials that
go into holding the panels up
in the field either on a roof
or out in the field.
So efficiency affects
pretty much everything
but the inverter and possibly
some of the soft costs
of the project.
That includes the
architect and the people
who you pay to handle the money,
financing, and the lawyers
perhaps.
So pretty much all of the
real material and labor costs
are scaling with area.
And so efficiency determines
that to a large degree,
and hence it's a
highly-leveraged way
to reduce the costs
of solar energy.
If you do a
sensitivity analysis,
which you will do in the second
and third parts of the class,
and look at the costs
of solar and how
it scales with
efficiency, you'll
see that efficiency is one
of the determining factors
for cost in a solar cell device.
And that's why we
focus on it a lot.
To put it into perspective,
if the efficiency up there is
determined by the output
power versus the input power,
if we had 100% conversion
efficiency, which is impossible
to achieve, thermodynamically
impossible to achieve,
we would produce a certain
amount of energy per unit time,
or a certain amount of
peak power, with this panel
right there.
Say that's the size of
our field installation.
If we had a 33%
efficiency cell, which
is closer to the
space-grade solar cells,
we'd need three times
that area, so three
times the encapsulants, three
times the glass, three times
the labor to install it.
And if we had a 20%
efficiency, say, high end
but still commercial
solar module,
not something you'd
need to get from NASA,
but something that you
could buy from a supplier,
you'd need five times that area.
Whereas if you had a 10%
efficiency module, which
is more approaching the
area of some relatively
inexpensive solar cells, you
would need 10 times that area.
So if you're doing
a cost analysis,
this is why efficiency matters.
It might still be
cheaper to use this
instead of to use
this over here.
That might very well be more
expensive when you do the math
and figure out how much it
costs to deposit those materials
with a very low
throughput deposition
process and very high cost.
It might still be,
but it might not.
The material costs might
end up whopping you.
And so a simple equation that
calculates all these parameters
in, the material costs,
the module efficiency,
essentially the material
[? and  labor ?] costs,
are being calculated in dollars
per meter squared, just saying,
how many dollars go into
producing a meter squared
of this material?
And the efficiency is over here.
And this is just a very
simple back-of-the-envelope
calculation type of way of
estimating the cost of a solar
system.
So if you say, OK, I'm
willing to pay more
for a high-efficiency cell
because I'm using less area,
you can use this
type of calculation
to get to the answer quickly.
It's not a levelized cost
of electricity analysis.
It's not using
discounted capital flows
and so forth, which we'll
get to later on in class.
This is a really
back-of-the-envelope envelope
engineering approach to
estimating costs of a solar
system.
So I think this is a
great place to stop.
And if anybody has a pitch
concerning their project
ideas, class project ideas,
I'd like to invite them
to the front now.
The class project, mind
you, is really the capstone
of this class, 2.626, 2.627.
So if you have an idea, a fun
idea, for a class project,
I'd invite you to give a pitch
up here at the front of class,
or you're welcome to send it on
an email to the class listserv.